Namo tassa bhagavato harhato sama sambuddhasa Namo tassa bhagavato harhato sama sambuddhasa Namo tassa bhagavato harhato sama sambuddhasa
Homage to the blessed, noble and fully self-enlightened one.
Before I begin the Dharma talk I want to give, which is on the wheel of dependent origination, I'll answer these two questions, which are to do with our meditation.
Ostatní otázky, které byly položeny, jsou obecnějšího charakteru.
Tak já na ně odpovím ke konci kurzu.
Co dělat se strachem?
Když se objeví náhle a není čas na to reagovat a připravit se na něj.
Panik.
Panika.
Někdy se strach objeví velmi rychle.
Když se strach objeví, tak naší reakce je samozřejmě strach.
Strach ze strachu.
A to je to, co záleží na paniku.
A to je to, co způsobuje tu paniku.
Takže když se to přihodí, tak se to přihodí.
Sklidníme se.
A budeme pokračovat meditaci.
A pomalu, během nějaké doby, budeme mít více věcí o těchto těchto těchto těch.
si zvykneme na ten pocit strachu, takže nás to nevyleká.
A nakonec budeme moci s tím v klidu sedět.
Jako kdyby to byl náš přítel.
Jako kdyby jste seděli s přítelem, který má velký strach.
A nakonec strach odejde.
Možná po třiceti letech.
Měl jsem říct někomu z těch,
Říkal jsem v jedné těch skupiněch, že můžete ochutit nebo okořenit váš pohled milující laskavostí, soucitem.
A to často změkčí vaši praxi.
To je takové jako dnes, když jsem říkal, že když pracujeme, musíme vytvářet důvěr a otázku.
Stejně jako ráno, když jsem říkal, že když pracujeme, tak musíme vytvořit péči a pozornost.
Takže ta pozornost je to dívání se.
A ta starost je tažením srdce do toho.
Řekněme, že přítel může být nemocný nebo mít obavy, tak k němu přijdeme a
Máme k němu samozřejmě pocit soucitu.
A tak tyto kvality můžeme také nasměrovat jako k nám.
A láska a soucit jsou protipóly strachu a nenávisti.
Kdyby na tohle bylo ještě víc otázek, tak mi je tam napište.
Další otázka je, zmínil jste duchovnost.
Co je to duchovnost?
A kde a jak se duchovnost
Já doufám, že dnešní hovor na obudově psychologii vám pomůže tomu porozumět.
Když slyšíte první knihy,
když čtete ty rané texty a Buddha odpovídá jednotlivcům, zdá se, že se soustředí na neuspokojivost
na neuspokojivost.
A tato centrální část kola závislého vznikání je představování, jak se děláme v závislým způsobem.
A to nám popisuje, jak děláme věci neprospěšně.
Začíná to rozpoznáním, že cokoliv vyvstává,
vystává buď v těle anebo v psychice.
Když mluvím o psychice, tak mám na mysli emoční život a myšlenkový život.
A způsob, jakým poznáváme, co se děje v těle a v psychice,
je skrze šest smyslů.
Pět už známe, oči, nos a tak dále.
A tím šestým smyslem je mysl sama.
Mysl, která přijímá, sbírá informace a nás představuje s faktem,
a vyzváří pro nás činnost vnímání.
Takže například my víme, že fotony, které vstupují do našeho oka,
Je velmi malý.
Já jsem viděl program, který ukazuje, že když se díváme na obraz, tak vidíme v podstatě jenom malé kousky v daný okamžik.
Oko vlastně po něm jezdí velmi rychle.
Ale to, co ve skutečnosti vidíme, je celý obraz.
Takže něco musí být v mozku, co pro nás vyrábí obraz, věci, které vidíme.
A potom to mysl vlastně promítne na ten předmět.
Takže si ve skutečnosti myslíme, že se díváme na obraz.
Ale
Na té základní kontaktní úrovni nevidíme ve skutečnosti nic.
Stejné je to se sluchem.
Pouze vzduchové vlny naráží na bubínek.
Je tam samozřejmě
Jak když cítíte vítr na vašich tvářích.
Ale ty jsou přenášeny do mozku a tam jsou přetvořeny ve zvuk.
A pak odtud jdeme do procesu, který je přetvořený jako zvuk.
A skrze toho my pak dojdeme k tomu, že to rozpoznáváme jako zvonek.
Takže zřejmě, to je naše západní věda, my z těchto...
Tak z těchto malých vstupů prostě vytváříme tento svět.
A buddhovo učení je o tom bodě dotyku.
On říká, že existuje tělo a psychika.
A také říká, že to jsou dvě rozdílné energie.
Nejsou stejné.
A v jednom skriptu říká, že podle nějakých práce meditace
V jednom ze svých textů říká, že skrz určitý druh praxe, meditace, můžete oddělit psychické tělo od fyzického těla, jako když vytahujete meč z pochvy, což velmi odporuje naší materiální věděn.
která věří, že všechno je hmota.
Ale z buddhistického pohledu, ačkoliv jsou tu dva druhy energie, nemůžeme říct, že jsou úplně jiné,
jsou prostě ve škále hrubé a jemné energie.
Ale z pohledu naší zkušenosti a způsobu, jak se naši zkušenosti
a způsobem, kterým v podstatě zkoumáme sami sebe a jak tělo a psychika musí spolupracovat spolu.
On říká, že tělo a psychika jsou jako mléko a voda.
Někdy při vaší meditaci
když se díváte na něco jako emoce, říkáte depresie, angst, zlost, něco jiného, můžete vidět oddělování.
A vidíte, že psychická emoce
a vidíte, že ty mentální psychické emoce, že nejsou tak bolestivé jako to tělo.
Tělo se zdá zvětšovat ten počitek té emoce.
Takže například zloba, zlost je emoce, která vyrábí teplo.
Takže to ovlivňuje tělo.
A my doslova cítíme někdy úplně takové pálivé věmy.
Já jsem toho zakusil.
A v té ospalosti a otupělosti to ovlivňuje tělo.
A tělo vyrábí tyhle chemikálie, které způsobí, že se cítíme tělo těžké.
V běžném životě je velmi těžké tyhle dvě oddělit.
Co se týká psychologie kolem neuspokojivosti,
Tak to není třeba příliš zkoušet.
Když zakoušíme oddělení těla od psychiky, je to více zkušeností anatá,
tedy ne já.
Předtím, kdy jsme si mysleli, že tady je pouze tělo, tedy já, tak teď se musíme rozhodnout, co jsem tedy já.
Někdy při zkušenostech blízké smrti
to psychické tělo vyskočí.
Měl jsem příběh o ženě, která měla autohavárii a zemřela.
Takže byla stává uvnitř ženy, která měla autohavárii.
tak ona stála vedle auta a dívala se na své tělo.
A když se dívala na tu řadu aut, každý ji na ním nadával.
Ale byla tam jedna žena, která se za ní modlila.
Říká, že viděla, že energie jí nadávala a pak se na ní nadávala.
Ona říkala, že viděla energii jít nahoru a pak se vracet do její hlavy.
Potom se ona uzdravila.
Takže koupila nějaké dárky a květiny a šla navštívit tu ženu, která se za ní modlila.
kteří si pamatovala její SPZ.
A když toto ponecháme stranou, tak se přeneseme do bodu běžných denních zážitků.
Buda říká, že v každém jednotlivém okamžiku existuje kontakt.
Aby se ten kontakt mohl stát, musí tady být tři věci.
Předmět, schopnost vnímat a vědomí.
Když ztratíte zrák, nic neuvidíte.
Když jste na prosté tně, tak taky nic nevidíte.
A když spíte, tak taky nic nevidíte.
V každém okamžiku našich dělých životů máme tenhle okamžik kontaktu.
hledně tohoto bodu se cítíme naprosto neutrální.
Není tam žádné, že se nám to líbí nebo nelíbí.
Ale pak, když se to stane zaujímavé,
A potom, když to počneme rozpoznávat, potom to vnímání a kvalita pociťování vyvstane.
Takže teď víme, že to je zvon a líbí se nám to.
Toto je vedena, bod pociťování.
Takže tady máme ten kontakt, který je neutrální a pociťování, který už může být líbí se, nelíbí se.
A také neutrální samozřejmě.
A v tomto bodě přichází reakce.
Když se mi to líbí, tak to chci, chci to ještě.
A když se mi to nelíbí, tak to nechci a už to nikdy nechci.
Když to nemůžu odstranit, tak to nechci.
tak uteču.
Takže tady máme v té naší zkušenosti dva neprospěšné kořeny, takzvané.
Všechny věci, které mají co do činění s pěním,
a všechny ty věci, které mají co do činí s nechtěním, strachem, nenávistí.
Všechny ty věci, jako je nenávist,
A verze v budově učení se ubyvají pod jedným slovem.
A verze.
Now at this point there is still no I.
Ale v tomto bodě pořád ještě není žádné oko.
Žádné já.
Já.
Sorry, I. Sorry, there is still no me, no I.
Akorát s tím chtěním tam pak přichází to já chci.
Tam se říká uchopení.
Takže je tady chtění a já chci.
A pak na tento punkt vytvoříme chtění.
A v tomto okamžiku my to chtění nabudíme, posílíme.
A to, co původně byl záměr, tak se najednou stává činem.
Vidíme sušenku, kontakt.
Máme ten pocit z toho vnímání velmi hezký.
Potom vytvoříme vztah.
Chci.
Teda tak předtím je to měli neutrální chtít a potom to zosobňujeme já chci.
A potom to popadneme.
A tenhle bod v kole závislého vznikání
se nazývá stávání se.
Toto stávání se znamená, že vytváříme podmiňování, zvyk.
A znovu v buddhistické psychologii,
A znovu buddhistické psychologii.
Vše začíná se záměrem.
Záměr vytváří akci, čin.
Mnoho činů vytváří zvyk.
A mnoho zvyků
vytváří osobnost.
A tato osobnost nás vede naším osudem.
Co naše meditace nám pomáhá vidět, je, jak jsme vytvářeli tyto habity,
je jak vytváříme tyto návyky, jak můžeme zastavit vytváření těchto návyků, změnit naši osobnost a posunout se k...
k zážnému osudu nebo tak v budoucnosti možná.
A toto stávání se je stejné jako karma.
A o tom budu mluvit více zítra.
Takže na...
Učení Budhy o tom, jak v nás vzniká neuspokojivost, je učením Duky.
Duka znamená si obtížné místo.
Místo, v kterém se nacházíme, je vytvořené námi.
My všichni sedíme v této místnosti.
Nikdo nebude popírat, že ta místnost neexistuje.
Je to tak?
Ale každý z nás zakouší tuto místnost jinak.
A vaše zkušenost nemůže být mojí.
Takže vidíte, že žijeme v paralelních vesmírech.
Je to úžasné, jak se můžeme komunikovat.
Je úžasný, jak můžeme spolu komunikovat.
A ještě ve skutečnosti spousta lidí mluví jinými jazyky.
Tak z toho meditačního pohledu ten bod pozornosti
je ten výsledek líbí se mi, nelíbí se, chci, nechci.
Když na tom můžeme podržet pozornost,
tak to chtění, nechtění nemůže být uchopeno.
Nemůžeme se s tím identifikovat.
Nestane se to nikdy tím já chci nebo já nechci.
A proto tento starý návyk se nemůže reprodukovat, množit.
Když má někdo naprosto nekontrolovatelnou touhu po sušenkách, nejrychlejší způsob, jak se z tohoto návyku zbavit, je položit pár lákavých sušenek před nás.
A pojďte se podívat.
A dívat se na ně.
A nejíst.
Počkejte, až ta bolest odejde.
To můžete udělat s jakýmkoliv návykem.
Mnoho lidí jsou... Co je to?
Co je to, které máme?
Máme silný návyk.
Adiktivní.
Mnoho lidí jsou závislí, řekněme, na televizi.
Vzáště na jednom programu.
Takové ty seriály, velký reality show.
Takže sedíme před televizí
Máte šálek dobrého čaje nebo kávy?
Ne, sušenky.
A prostě vy to nezapnete.
A budete se dívat na tu obrazovku, než ten program skočí.
Musíte to dělat do té doby, než nebudete mít chůjce na ten program dívat.
Pak se na to můžete znovu podívat, ale musíte si dát pozor na to rostoucí ulpění.
A tohle bylo zároveň zároveň zároveň zároveň
A to byl důvod pro starý křesťanský půst.
Po určitou část roku jste se vzdali něčeho, co jste rádi dělali nebo jedli.
Abyste nechali ty silné touhy odejít.
Nyní mají lidé diety.
Dieta není ze žádných duchovních důvodů.
To je jenom proto, abyste mohli jíst znovu úplně stejně, jak jste jedli předtím.
Takže tady upadáme do...
toho začarovaného kruhu jezení a nejezení.
A to je to, co buddha myslel karmou a dukou.
Kolo závislého vznikání může být pochopeno dvěma způsobama.
Může být chápáno dvěma způsoby.
Něco, co se odehrává během několika okamžiků.
A nebo něco, co se odehrává během tří životů.
Možná, že o té teorii tří životů můžeme pohovořit zítra.
Pro nás je mnohem důležitější pochopit, jak to funguje teď.
Co já jsem popsal, je střední část toho kola.
To slovo začíná slovem avidža.
Avidža znamená
Aby čas jednodušeně znamená nevědět.
Není tím myšlená nevědomost takovým hloupým způsobem.
Když si vezmete čerstvě narozené děcko, co to zná?
co ono ví.
Ví velmi málo, spíš nic.
Pak začne zakoušet život a docela pochopitelně předpokládá, že je tím, co zakouší.
Já jsem ta bolest, já jsem ten hlad.
Takže hned od počátku jsme udělali nějaké malé chyby.
Stali jsme se budhovými slovy zaslepení.
My si myslíme, že jsme lidské bytosti.
Veliká chyba.
A z této ignorance máme vztah ke světu.
Zaslepený vztah.
Já věřím, že já jsem toto tělo a tato psychika.
A mojí touhou je, abych byl šťastný a unikl bolesti.
Tak si můžete všimnout, že když se naučím, jak se stát šťastným, tak se chci stát ještě více šťastným.
Začnu tím, že dostanu peníze za to, co udělám a líbí se mi to.
Takže hned mám velké nápady, že můžu dělat další věci.
To znamená více peněz.
A tak se rozhodnu stát se bohatým.
A myslím si, že nebudu šťastný, než se stanu miliardářem.
Protože srovnávám moje štěstí s mojím bohatstvím.
Nebo to můžeme teď dělat se slávou, chtít být slavný.
Být milován, být znám.
Když mi lidé nemají rádi, cítím se strašně.
Nebo taky s mocí.
Chci moc.
Kdybych mohl vládnout světu, byl bych velmi šťastný.
Nebo můžu sbírat tolik věmů jako počitků, kolik jen mohu.
Sex, drugs and rock'n'roll.
Sex, drogy a rock'n'roll.
To mě dělá šťastný.
Vše pochází z identifikace s touto formou.
Když budu šťastný, musím se cítit šťastný.
Když budu šťastný, chci se cítit šťastný.
Mé tělo musí být v pořádku.
Měřím mé štěstí mým fyzickým bytím.
A...
příjemnými pocity, které mohu cítit.
Rozrušujícími myšlenkami a myšlením.
A tento druh postoje mě přivádí do konfliktu se světem.
Protože já budu od světa chtít víc, než on chce ode mě.
Vidíte, že toto je základní psychologie kapitalismu.
A nikdy to nekončí.
A na druhé straně tady jsou věci, které já nechci, které mě dělají nešťastný.
Může to být hudba od souseda.
Politika.
Cokoliv, co mě činí nešťastným, chci odstrčit.
Takže všechny ty pocity ohledně zloby a nenávisti zůstají.
A znovu se nacházím v konfliktu.
A znovu, když je opozicí hodně velká, tak se začínám cítit těžký, těžký, a tak dále.
A když ta opozice je příliš velká, tak se samozřejmě cítím v obavách.
A to vše vzniká, protože je tady smyslová zaslepenost.
že částí naší meditace je rozložit lidskou bytost a najít k ní úplně jiný vztah.
A když najdeme ten úplně jiný vztah, už více nechceme, co nám svět může dát,
A konflikt, když svět se obrátí proti nám.
Takže Buddha řekl, že svět se jaksi hádal s ním, a ne on se světem.
A když řekl o tom,
A když mluvil o tom, jak někdo zakouší svět, když nemá tuto zaslepenost, řekl, že byli spokojení a šťastní.
Tak to je tam, kam se chceme dostat,
A co právě meditace činí, je že podkopává zaslepenost, která vytváří utrpení.
Takže kdybych měl zestručnit, zkrátit celé to budovo učení týkající se utrpení,
Všechnu psychologickou bolest způsobujeme sami.
Nejprve je to zklamání.
Protože od teď jsem měl blížit matku.
Protože doteď jsem mohl za to vinit mojí matku, nebo otce, a mojí společnost, a svět, a Boha.
Ale teď už musím vzít veškerou odpovědnost za moje mentální stavy.
A zde vzniká naše pravda,
A v tom leží naše skutečná naděje.
A protože stejně jako jsme tento psychologický kruh, když jsme vytvořili tento psychologickou bolest, můžeme ji zrušit.
A navíc
v procesu toho rušení té psychologické bolesti, se nic nestrácí.
Vše je transformováno, proměněno.
A to je vyjádřeno
V druhém bodě osmidílné stezky.
Správný postoj.
Veškerá sobecko se promění ve štědrost.
Veškerá nenávist se promění v lásku.
Veškerá krůlost se promění v lásku.
A veškerá krutost se promění v souci.
Můžete si vzít jakoukoliv negativní kvalitu a ona se promění ve svůj opak.
Například v naší meditaci jsme mluvili o nudě.
Vítejte.
energie nudy se promění vzájem.
Tak to je cesta, na které jsme, která se týká charakteristik, které se nazývají dukkha.
Tak...
Kdybyste měli nějaké otázky, které se do toho týkají, tak je dejte tam do sklenice.